this is a robotic shoulder
but inside it are human cells undergoing
a vigorous exercise routine
this setup has been developed to mimic
the conditions of the human body where
cells can be pushed and pulled and
stretched in different directions
if it works one day human patients could
be treated with tissue grafts grown in
robots
growing cells in a lab is easy enough
they need nutrients oxygen and something
to grow in or on a petri dish for
example can give cells everything they
need to thrive
for pier mutually however a petri dish
wasn't quite
enough here wants to grow tendon cells
the tough bits of tissue that connect
muscles and bones
he hopes lab-grown cells could one day
be grafted into human bodies to repair
tears in shoulder tendons for example
but there's a catch
we are still
far away from a fully functional tandem
tissue grafts and
we think that partially this is because
we are not providing
the same complexity
of mechanical stresses around those
cells a petri dish is not the natural
home of a human cell and it seems that
some cells need an environment that's a
little bit more stimulating what
researchers have shown for for a long
time now is that external mechanical
stimulation is really key to mature the
tissue properly and to have the cells
express the right type of genes and to
produce the right extracellular matrix
instead of a petri dish or bioreactor
flask researchers grow tendon cells on
stretchy plastic scaffolds with fluid
providing the oxygen and nutrients this
small chamber is pierre's team's new
flexible design
so far scientists have used repeated
stretching and relaxing to stimulate the
cells to grow properly
but unidirectional stretching like this
is pretty different from what tendons
would experience in a real shoulder what
the body is providing to native tissues
is multi-axial mechanical stimulation
where you have three-dimensional
mechanical stresses being applied to
tissue constructs in the form of not
just tension but also compression and
torsion pierre's new chambers can be
pushed pulled bent and twisted just like
a real tendon but he still needed
something to do all that pushing pulling
bending and twisting what he needed was
a robot
what you're seeing here is a robot and
that's a humanoid robotic avatar and
what makes them special is that they
have muscles and tendons as we humans do
so we try to imitate the way the human
body works
and we're doing this because we believe
it's going to help us build robots that
are eventually going to move just as
natural
and graciously as human bodies do
they're being used in research
neuroscience
biomechanics and so on but eventually
they might be used to build better
prosthetics and test new implants these
robots are intended to mimic the shape
the dimensions and the mechanics of the
human body
and one day i got an email from a
certain pm3 in my inbox asking me
whether i'd be interested
of using his robots to put tendons on
top of them and grow them and of course
i was like hell yeah that's exactly
in line with where we want to be going
eventually pretty soon pierre's lab had
their very own robot shoulder
so what you can see
is that one side of that chamber is
being attached to the humerus heads
to the bone like structure that you see
on this end and the other side of the
chamber is attached to a string that is
then linked to the motor which is acting
as a muscle but pierre wasn't satisfied
with an arm that just moves up and down
so this is now a newer version of our
robotic shoulder it allows us a more
complete range of motion of the human
shoulder so not just abduction abduction
but also
this sort of rotation and you see that
now the arm is moving in multiple
directions this new method was designed
to grow tendons to graft onto shoulder
injuries but there are other possible
applications to look at improving
rehabilitation exercises
by looking at how the cells are being
affected by a particular exercise
or it could also be used in
translational research to screen through
biomaterials to ensure that they are
mechanically suitable for humans now
that they've developed the system to
make it work the team's next step is to
figure out whether this new robotic
petri dish can actually grow better
tendons than the old-fashioned method so
this has been years of work already
and obviously now we've demonstrated
that it is feasible to use this approach
and i think the fun only starts now
because now that we've demonstrated that
it's feasible to use those humanity
robots
we can explore the different
possibilities that we can do and look
into whether it can really help to
improve the quality of the crafts by
providing these more physiologically
relevant mechanical stresses
bye